hey everybody i'm nate from huggingface
and today let's build an app to play
pictionary using gradio and pytorch
now this video is based on a guide that
you can find on the gradio site which
i'll link to our goal is to see how well
an algorithm can tell what we're drawing
to do that we'll use a model that i
already trained using the quick draw
data set which was released by google
the quick draw data set contains a bunch
of hand-drawn images of a variety of
objects
if you're curious you can play with a
notebook i used to train this model to
train your own my guess is you could
probably figure out how to make a better
one so go ahead
we're going to use hugging face spaces
to host our app for free so let's go
ahead and create a new space
we'll name it pictionary and make sure
to specify gradio once it's created
we'll get clone it to our local machine
now here you'll see that i already
downloaded a couple files one is
classnames.txt which is a file that
contains the associated class names that
our pre-trained model knows how to
predict
the other one is pytorch model.bin which
is that pre-trained model as a saved
file
now we'll copy both these files into the
repo we just cloned
next let's create a requirement.txt file
to define our python dependencies in
this case it's torch and gradio
after that we'll create an app.pi file
to define our app and here we'll start
by defining some imports
then we'll read in our labels into a
string list from the classnames.txt file
after that we'll have to define the
model that we want to load to do that
i'm going to go back to the gradio guide
and copy in some lines from uh from that
guide into our application file
so this is our model definition followed
by code to load the pi torch model bin
waits and set the model in evaluation
mode so it's ready to make predictions
now gradual apps work by defining a
prediction function which we'll do here
the im variable coming in here is a
numpy array that's scaled from 0 to 255.
so we'll quickly quickly convert that to
a tensor and scale it between 0 and 1.
after that it's standard pytorch
prediction code where we're going to use
a torch.nograd context manager to get
the outputs use softmax to get the
probabilities and then call torch.top k
to get the top five predicted label
indices
we'll finish off by using those indices
to look up the string names of the
labels and return them with the mapping
to their predicted probabilities
sweet so now that we have the prediction
function we just have to define the
interface so we'll use a gradio
interface make sure to pass it the
prediction function we just defined and
then we're going to specify for the
inputs that it's sketchpad which is the
thing that lets you draw uh and then the
outputs are going to be label
and something also important here is
that we're going to specify live equals
true which means that as we draw we're
going to get live predictions back then
we'll just call interface.launch awesome
let's try this locally
and
it seems to be working so that's great
let's share with the world on hug and
face spaces by pushing up to the repo
that we created earlier
after waiting for a minute for the space
to build we can play with the app in our
browser
now again this model is not perfect so i
encourage you to check out the training
code and train one that's even better
bonus points if you're able to make one
that's better and includes all the
classes from the quick draw data set
instead of the 100 that i limited to
so
that's how you build a pictionary app
using radio and pi torch if you find
this video helpful give it a like and
consider subscribing to our youtube
channel for more content like this
you can also join our discord server to
join thousands of other folks interested
in machine learning
until next time thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you